Kevin Hart Mourns the death of his dad
Henry Witherspoon you know you're loved
and and I think being loved by the ones
that matter the most it's uh it's a it's
a it's an over a feeling that overcomes
you at the most inopportune times the
actors shared the news in an emotional
post to Instagram Thursday sharing these
snaps alongside the caption R.I.P to one
of the realest and rawest to ever do it
love you Dad gone but never forgotten
give Mom a hug for me y'all did good man
thank you for everything the comedian
and data for added quote I'm a better
father because of you we will all make
you proud my kids actually think I'm the
coolest dad on the planet it's different
when you think you cool and your parents
like shut up Dad like you're not cool
but they actually think I'm real cool
but I know why I am the way that I am
see my dad has a lot to do with that
back in 2017 Kevin got candid about how
he repaired his once troubled
relationship with his father and how he
learned to be a better dad by not
repeating his dad's past the mistakes
that my dad made you know the decisions
to do drugs being and out of jail in and
out of our Lives I saw firsthand with
not being present did and because of
that I now know what being present means
I know what that can do I know the
effect that it'll have on your child
coming up now I was strong enough to
deal with it coming up because I have a
different attitude I'm I'm a positive
guy I choose to go positive instead of
negative a lot and because of that my
relationship with my dad is is amazing
now and over the years Kevin has beamed
about being a dad to E.T it's been great
man yeah I have no complaints at all
very blessed very happy uh and you know
looking to expand his legacy the last
name of heart lives on Generations now
we got generations of it we're in love
with being parents but more importantly
I'm in love with seeing Foundation
grow I'm in love with seeing my kids
develop into to people you know it's for
a long period of time you look at your
kids kids the kids right and then as
they get older and start to mature
you're like these are young adults as a
father uh I'm sitting in a in a in a
hell of a happy chair right now and it's
only going to get better
[Music]